Let's review everything we've
done in the last few videos
and then take it a few
steps from there.
So let's say we have a reality
that right now-- and this
isn't the actual exchange rate,
but I'm just using these
numbers because they're nice
simple numbers-- the current
exchange rate is 10
yuan per U.S. $1.
And now we're in a reality where
the Chinese Government,
the Chinese Central Bank,
wants to keep this
[? PEG'd, ?]
so it wants to lock this.
It wants to lock this exchange
rate right over here.
But the reality is, more is
being sold to the U.S., more
is being exported from China
to the U.S. than
the other way around.
And so that leads to this
weird dynamic that we've
studied in the last
few videos.
So this is China right here, and
then you have the United
States right over here.
And let's say at this exchange
rate right over here, you have
goods coming from China to the
U.S. Actually, let me do it in
that same magenta color.
So these are Chinese goods,
and then we are paying for
those Chinese goods in dollars
and those dollars are being
sent to China.
So let's say we pay in
this time period.
Let's say it's a year.
Let's say that $100 sent to
China for the goods, and this
is really just a summary
of what we saw in
the last few videos.
And let's say, on the other side
of this equation, some
goods are sent from
the U.S. to China.
Some are exported, so U.S. goods
are exported to China,
and then we sell them in China
and then we get some yuan in
return that go back to
the United States.
And, of course, the reality is
that the money seldom is
actually sitting on a ship
going across the Pacific.
It's all in these bank accounts
that can be wired
back and forth.
The actual exchanges are
essentially happening on the
internet, not really in any
physical location, but this is
a good way to visualize it.
So the U.S. goods are being
sold in China and then the
U.S. producer is going
to get yuan.
And let's say for their goods,
they get 500 yuan.
So if all of these people were
just convert, and you actually
don't know what the equilibrium
price would be,
because the demand changes
depending on what the price is
in each of the countries, but
if you really wanted to
convert these $100 that the
Chinese producer gets into
yuan at 10:1, you would need--
so we're going to assume that
this PEG is what at least the
Chinese Government wants.
So you would need 1,000 yuan in
order to convert all of his
$100 at 10 yuan per dollar.
Now this producer, the U.S.
producer, only has-- let me do
it in a different color and I
should put the quotes around
needs, not around the yuan.
Now this U.S. producer only has
500 yuan to convert into
dollars, and we've seen
this multiple times.
But I really want to reinforce
it about how these currencies
would fluctuate.
The demand for yuan is much
higher than supply for yuan.
And we could do the exact same
argument for the dollar, that
the demand for dollars
is much lower than
the supply for dollars.
At this exchange rate, if we
assumed a PEG, this would only
be $50 that we need to convert
into, while there's $100 of
actual supply.
But let's just focus
on the yuan.
They need 1,000 yuan at
this exchange rate.
There's only 1,000 yuan that can
be converted into dollars.
And if we had a floating
exchange rate, that would
increase the demand for yuan,
and then this number would go
down, or another way to view
it, either that number goes
down or this number
over here goes up.
You could say the yuan would
become more expensive, which
means maybe it's 9 yuan per
dollar or 8 yuan per dollar,
or it could go the other way.
For 10 yuan, instead of $1,
you'd get $1.10 or $1.20 or
$1.30, either way.
Now, in order for this lock and
for this PEG to occur, we
saw in the last video that
the Chinese Central
Bank needs to intervene.
Remember, where are the
excess dollars?
They're over here.
Let me make it clear.
There's $100 over here
that need to be
converted into yuan.
We have 500 yuan over here that
needs to be converted
into dollars.
Now, the Chinese government
wants this $100 to be
converted into 1,000 yuan.
So what he does or what they
do is they say, OK, $50 of
this $100 dollars can be
essentially traded
for these 500 yuan.
Let me draw a two-way arrow
there. $50 goes to the
American producer and then the
500 yuan go to the Chinese
producer in exchange
for that $50.
Obviously, this isn't
coordinated.
It's not like matchmaking.
It's not like someone
said, hey, you give
this money to them.
But essentially, there will only
be $50 to convert into
the yuan and then the other
$50 will go to the Chinese
Central Bank.
Let me draw the Chinese Central
Bank, and they will
just print yuan and give
another 500 yuan.
And this is exactly what
happened in the last video.
I drew it a little
bit different.
All I'm showing is to make up
for the lack of supply of
yuan, they needed 1,000
yuan, there's
only 500 yuan to convert.
In order to make that up, the
Chinese Central Government
prints the extra Chinese
currency and buys
dollars with it.
So it's essentially sucking up
the excess dollars, right?
This was excess dollars right
over here so that the dollar
does not weaken.
It is sucking up extra dollars
so that the supply for dollars
isn't so high that it weakens
or so that the yuan
strengthens.
And so that's the way
the Chinese can
maintain the trade imbalance.
They could continue to
export more goods
than they are importing.
Now, what is the effect
of this, though?
And we saw this.
In order to maintain this
currency PEG while there is
this trade imbalance, the
Chinese Central Bank keeps
printing yuan and they keep
accumulating dollars.
And if they ever stop
accumulating dollars, so it's
not like they can just hold the
dollars they have and the
PEG will hold.
If they ever stop accumulating
dollars, then the PEG will
break down.
They have to do this
every time period.
They have to actively
participate in the market
printing yuan and
buying dollars.
They are doing it every day
to maintain the PEG.
Not every day, maybe sometimes
when it won't fluctuate on
their own, but if the yuan is
getting expensive, they
actually maintain a range, and
they will buy dollars.
So they're just accumulating
more and
more of these dollars.
And now this is where
it gets interesting.
What does the Chinese Central
Bank do with that cash?
Now, like anybody,
cash is useless.
You're not getting any
interest on it.
It's just paper.
It allows you to buy other
things that could give you
some income or could give
you some value.
So what the Chinese Central
Bank does, it doesn't hold
actual dollar bills.
It goes and tries to buy
the safest U.S.-
denominated asset it can.
And another thing, not only does
it care about safety-- so
it wants to go to
a safe asset.
It wants to go to the safe
dollar-denominated asset,
which means that you would buy
it in dollars, and if it
produces interest, the interest
would be in dollars.
And it's also doing this on a
massive, massive scale, in the
hundreds of billions of dollars,
and actually the
Reserve is in the trillions
of dollars, so it's
on a massive scale.
So they can't just go buy a
random company's stock, one
that won't be safe, but also
they would just drive the
price up to infinity if they
used this many dollars.
So it has to be a very liquid
asset, one that has a very
deep market where the people
trading in that market, it
really is in the tens
and hundreds
of billions of dollars.
And there's really only one
asset that meets those
requirements, and that's
U.S. Treasuries.
And this isn't the only thing
they will do, but this is the
great majority.
So what the Chinese Central Bank
does with all of these
excess dollars, it essentially
buys U.S. Treasuries.
So it gives the dollars away.
Well, not gives away, it sends
the dollars to the people who
are holding the U.S. Treasuries,
and then it gets
U.S. Treasuries in return.
Now, as a bit of review, and
I've done a few videos on
this, what are U.S.
Treasuries?
U.S. Treasury bills and bonds
are loans to the Federal
Government.
So that's maybe how you
should view it.
These are loans to the
Federal Government.
These bonds, these Treasury
bonds or these treasury bills
that they're getting, these
certificates, are
essentially-- in fact, they
are-- IOUs from the U.S.A, not
to get cheesy with the acronyms.
These are literally
IOUs from the U.S. Government,
and the U.S. Government will
pay interest. They are
essentially-- so just to make
it all clear of what's going
on, they're printing money.
They're accumulating dollars.
They're using those dollars to
go out into either the open
market or even directly from
the Treasury, from the U.S.
Treasury, and they are buying
U.S. Treasuries, which
essentially means that they are
lending this money to the
U.S. Government.
Now, I'll leave you there in
this video, and maybe you want
to think about it a little
bit before you even
watch the next one.
But in the next one, we'll talk
a little bit about what
that even means.
What happens if you have this
big holder of U.S. dollars,
this huge holder of U.S. dollars
going out there and
buying Treasuries and being
willing to lend money to the
U.S. Government?
Think about it.
And in particular, think about
what would happen to interest
rates and what those low
interest rates' impact would
have on the rest of
the U.S. economy
and on debt in general.